[Musique]
à
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens
je me déplace uniquement avec ceux avec
ses transports soient en bus ou en métro
je pars de chez moi je me rends la
destination que je veux et petit à petit
je découvre le plat la capitale voilà et
votre frère il en pense quoi
mon frère je fais pas de frère bonjour
santé mentale et vous ça va c'est
qu'elle gêne on regarde sa série noire
jamais nous avons un rendez-vous
faudrait que maintenant nous quittions
avec en arranger vont pas prendre tous
les héritages où connery à 10 cm sur le
podium
généralement la ville est plutôt bien
des services cependant il peut y avoir
des problèmes de circulation et ça peut
vite devenir une gêne le métro restent à
quai qui devrait partir on nous annonce
qui va repartir dans cinq minutes et
puis finalement et votre choix
mon frère a eu
non on n'a peu près du même avis c'est
certain que
il ya des complications on se connaît
dans ce convoi
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens je n'en pense pas
grand chose car je les utilise très peu
raison ce que j'ai un scooter et un vélo
et pourquoi vous n'avez pas aimé et
transforme pas pour utiliser le recul
scooter ou le vélo
non j'aime juste être libre et comment
être plus libres qu'avec un vélo
comprend quand on allait décider où
quand on prend le son twitter et votre
challenge quoi ma soeur j'aimerais bien
qu'elle n'est ce pas toi comment tu vas
pas mal à ce sport c'est marrant qu'on
soit là ouais ramène pas l'autre concept
x banon j'ai changé je souhaite pas au
courant de ça je te raconterai ce soir
plus gré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]